foreign
[Music]
it's really exciting to be presenting to
you today thank you very much for taking
the time to join us as you all heard my
name is Ruben Azhar and be your
presenter for today
I'm gonna be talking about our newest
automated platform the Emma Quattro for
plasmid purification
today I'm going to be talking about uh
quickly about an introduction of how we
ended up bringing this product to the
market as well as the products itself
and all the features I'll also take you
through the workflow followed by the
test data and the performance and lastly
I'm going to be talking about the
related products that could help you
whether you're working upstream or
Downstream from plasmid purification and
I will be giving you a sneak peek into
our next project that we're actively
working on at transcript
so I actually started my career early on
with plasmid purification and it was one
of the most challenging and most tedious
pain points that I got to experience in
a laboratory
later on I ended up working with
automation at various roles including as
a user as well as a company that
actually made the robotic liquid
handling platforms and I was able to get
a sense of what are the wonderful
aspects of automation as well as the
limitations of automation so I hope that
what you see today from the solution
standpoint is going to be delivering on
some of those pain points and
eliminating the challenges that are more
limiting in the automation world
so plasmids have actually been around
for many many years coming up actually
on 100 years
the actual term plasmid was introduced
in early 50s and it was around the 70s
that the DNA cloning technology was
introduced around 1980s was when the
purification of the plasmid was finally
done successfully with various methods
which actually ended up really changing
the way a lot of the laboratory work
around plasmids and transfecting ended
up taking place
so whenever we talk about plasmids we
have to think about the different
requirements as well as the different
challenges with every
um particular application that plasmids
are being used on
so whenever we're working with plasmids
on a smaller scale or maybe on a
research scale
the requirements are not going to be as
stringent and not as limiting as they
would be in a clinical setting of course
industrial is going to be in between but
that's really going to be closer of
course to the pre-clinical or clinical
grade plasmid so the higher up you go in
the scheme of of quality typically also
the requirements for the quantity so of
course when you're doing molecular
cloning you're going to be using smaller
quantities of plasmid DNA when you're
going into the transfection and antibody
production or any kind of therapeutic
production you're going to be using
significantly more plasma DNA and of
course the requirement the quality of
the plasmid is going to be very
different than when you are working with
positive DNA in a research set
so of course there's been quite a bit of
different methodology identified for the
purification of the plasmid itself
um quite a bit of them are are going to
be
um you know impacting the downstream
application
um but of course at this point in in the
laboratory setting majority of the
people are really using the alkaline
lysis
where you're using chemicals to burst
the E coli cell open to get the plasmid
out of that host that you've grown it
so of course a lot of the common
methodologies are going to be column
filter based where you have to basically
lice yourself open take that um they
take that license neutralize it and then
of course run it through that column and
take it through the series of washes
followed by illusion that is of course a
very labor intensive step but that is
actually one of the most commonly used
methodologies
every single method that you're seeing
up here has its own
value and it has also its own
um
Downstream application that could cause
challenges
from the janscript perspective we
actually based our Solution on the
magnetic silica beads as we found that
this is really the most optimal way to
handle large scale volume as well as
large scale throughput
so what you're seeing in front of you
right now is actually the traditional
plasmid purification with regards to
again what is typically used which is of
course the filter column
so every step almost every step that
you're seeing here there's typically a
centrifugation stop so you go from your
resuspension of your plasmid of your of
your bacteria into the license the
neutralization
of course you do a centrifugation here
you do your binding and then a series of
washes which again require a
centrifugation at every single one of
them and lastly your illusion the
process is not only very intensive with
regards to pipe petting but also very
intensive with regards to centrifugation
as we mentioned earlier
it's also very time consuming and the
biggest challenge ends up coming up
whenever you're working with large
volume of liquid
so you end up severely slowing down I
think that usually people would agree
that if you're working with a mini prop
scale it typically takes you less than
an hour but when you're working with
maxi Mega or even Giga it typically
takes you half a day to purify a very
few samples maybe even three or four and
it ends up taking you a significant
amount of time
so with that said
the junk script team came up with
what you're seeing in front of you which
is a completely automated large-scale
High throughput plasmid purification
solution
the solution is actually a complete
all-inclusive solution it's not only the
automated platform but it also includes
the verify protocols that are
pre-programmed onto the instrument
the actual consumables as well that are
needed to run the plasmid purification
are also part of the solution so with
that said what the user will end up
obtaining with this one basically one
comprehensive solution is that an out of
the box ready to go set up so the user
theoretically can purchase the system
take it out of the box load their
culture onto it load the actual
consumables and hit go within a few
hours of getting the instrument
so scientists now don't have to do their
their own validation their own
verification we made sure that the
protocols that are pre-grown programmed
into the solution into the system are
actually verified and work very well
with a wide variety of different plasmid
setups
another thing that is that was key in
the design of the instrument which I
think speaks miles of the expertise of
the janscript team and understanding the
pain points of not only throughput but
also automation is the fact that the
solution is actually scalable and
completely modular
so what you're seeing in front of you is
actually to the right hand side is the
controller that can control up to four
modules that are completely independent
of one another
so the four modules to the left hand
side are individual purification modules
that are completely ran and dependent of
one another so if a scientist is okay
with a setup of six samples at a time
they don't need more than one module so
One controller and one module is capable
of running six samples at a time
if they're throughput grows a few months
later not a problem they can add another
module to this setup or maybe a third or
a fourth as their system needs grow and
they're throughput groups
so with that said again I want to
highlight the fact that each one is
completely independent of one another
and each module can be ran and dependent
of one another so if you want to run a
different program or if you want to run
a different um different times of the
day not a problem each one is completely
independent of one another
so as I mentioned before if you have a
four module setup with six samples free
for each module that means you can
actually run 24 samples in one go
system itself of course is a pipetting
liquid Handler and the Precision of the
padding is really good it's actually a
CV of three percent
and one thing I want to highlight here
is typically that the culture limitation
the volume of the bacterial culture is
not necessarily what I would
basically specify would be the
limitation it's really the bacterial
palette once the sample is centrifuge
down
so the first thing that the you that the
scientist has to do is grow their
culture overnight
in their media and then they have to
actually spin down that culture and
weigh that bacterial wet palette that
bacterial palette has a range that we
have
um identified to be optimal for the
Quattro set the optimal range is going
to be 0.3 to 1.5 bacterial watt palette
so if you're less than that quality of
the plasmid of the DNA might not be as
good if you're higher than that you're
not going to get good lysis which of
course indicates you're not going to be
able to obtain your DNA which is very
similar to really any kind of license
step this is not unique to the
JavaScript solution
the run time is going to be
approximately two hours so theoretically
you can typically run this instrument
probably three times a day the runtime
of course varies on depending on the
protocol you that you're running so two
to two and a half hours are going to be
the typical run times
what you will end up with is
transfection ready purified plasmid
which of course means High Purity
plasmid that has low endotoxins
below 0.1 EU per microgram and a very
high super cold ratio which is exceeding
the 80 to 90 percent ratio that is
typically indicative of the quality of
the plasmid that you're working with so
a lot of people think that the super
cold ratio is one of the key factors
that are going to be indicating whether
or not you're going to be successful in
your Downstream application so Studies
have actually shown that
and as I mentioned earlier in the slide
before the consumable kit is included in
the solution it includes the the
um the full scope of what is needed to
run the AMA Quattro plasma purification
cell
um the consumable itself is
all-inclusive and I'll talk about that
in the next slide but this is something
that I really want to highlight because
it's something that is not typically
done in any kind of um setup usually the
the user or the scientist has to
actually Supply additional components to
be able to run this solution
and lastly but definitely not least is
the use or the ease of use of the
interface so I mentioned before that the
solution has the pre-programmed verified
protocols
this is again included in this system
however if the scientist wants to
program their own protocol not a problem
they can actually do that using the
interface and I will give you an example
of the interface in a little bit but it
is very user friendly and there's quite
a bit of different checks that we
implemented to ensure correct loading of
the instrument as well as metrics that
don't violate the the various
recommendations that we have that we
know will enable you to be successful so
again it speaks to the expertise of the
JavaScript solution and the team that
actually worked on this platform and
this consumer
so this is basically
um the consumable kit what you're seeing
in front of you is actually the tip box
that includes a filter tube that will be
the final illusion to this is loaded up
here in the platform
the next component in the consumable is
the reagent cartridge this reagent
cartridge contains all the magnetic
beads that I mentioned before as well as
the buffers
and the wash
wash buffers and the illusion
it also includes all the tubes as well
as the waste so as you can see here it
is an all-inclusive kit you do not need
to worry about ordering multiple
components to run this platform it is
completely
completely included in one it's all in
one
and one of the nice things about the
transcript kit is that it is very cost
effective one of the biggest things
about Maxi Mega and Giga perhaps the
fact that the actual cost per sample is
fairly high
so of course when you automate typically
people want to see some cost savings
whether it's labor or whether it's from
a consumable standpoint you will see
that the consumable for the transcript
solution is actually less than the
market average and again all inclusive
of all the different components that are
needed
so I want to take a couple minutes to
actually introduce you to the full
workflow what you're seeing here within
the blue haloed box is completely
automated so this is not something that
the scientist has to worry about but I
still wanted to take a few moments to
talk about the full workflow because I
do think it's really interesting to
understand how the solution works
everything outside of the Halo box is
actually manual
so as I mentioned before the first step
of course when you're doing plasmid
purification is to grow your culture
offline
um once your culture is grown you're
going to take your Emma Quattro tube and
you're going to centrifuge your culture
using that Mac water tube so one of the
big things about using um the
consumables is that they're
pre-configured to fit into the janscript
solution but they also have other
components tied to the way that the
system works so for example the tube
that is used in the Gen script setup
actually has internal baffles that
enables really good resuspension of the
bacterial palette as well as really good
mixing when you're binding that plasma
DNA
so that particular tube is going to be
used
to go ahead and load your bacterial
palette into it so one thing that the
scientists can choose if they are
working with a really large volume they
could potentially centrifuge the
bacterial palette using their own flask
and then remove that that bacteria
palette scoop it out and put it into the
tube or again they can use that my that
tube to basically spin down the culture
once the spinning down of the culture is
done you go ahead and you load your
bacterial palette onto the instrument
deck of course you pour off that
supinated you load your tips you load
your tubes and of course you load your
reagent cartridge you go ahead and hit
start
and again everything you're seeing in
that blue haloed box is completely
automated so the instrument will take
the first step of basically resuspending
the bacterial palette it's going to do
the license the neutralization followed
by the pre-clarification
step which of course is usually removing
the host DNA as well as the cell debris
and other contaminating components once
the cell has been lysed that of course
includes proteins RNA all kinds of
contaminants that would be in your in
your solution
after you remove that debris and that
contaminating um
um basically components you're going to
go ahead and bind your plasma DNA after
The Binding the system will go ahead and
do a series of washes
that include specified washes to include
those endotoxins
so that will really enable us to get to
that really pure plasmid after that the
system will go ahead and perform an
illusion
and the final step is to remove that
illusion remove
um
the full
supernatant and dispenser into that I
you probably remember from my previous
slide into that illusion tube that
contains the filter
so once the illusion tube has been
um the liquid has been dispensed into
that Aleutian tube the run is complete
so the the scientists will walk up to
the instrument cap that tube containing
the eluded DNA and centrifugia Offline
that final centrifugation step through
that filter in that column it's going to
remove any Trace residual endotoxins as
well as any residual magnetic beads this
is a very important step to remove any
final endotoxins so I definitely do not
recommend skipping that step however if
you choose that as something that you
technically can skip
and that's basically it so again
centrifugation at the beginning to
ensure that you are you know ready to go
into your resuspension and then
centrifugation after you've done your
illusion those are the only two manual
setups at the beginning and of course at
the end of The Run
what you're seeing now is the user
interface which the first screen that
you're seeing on the top left corner is
showing you the main controller so as I
mentioned before the actual controller
can control up to four modules and this
for this particular example you can see
that the what the system is connected to
only one module so only one module is
online while the remainder modules are
great at because they're technically
offline
um when you go into module number one
there's a couple different settings that
you can actually select from you can do
either programming you can export this
is basically a exporting the runs that
you have conducted before you can go
into the general settings and of course
you can do system upgrades on the
instrument itself basically this is just
showing you the different parameters
that the user will have control over
so this is actually my favorite part of
the interface or maybe my second
favorite I'll talk about a couple other
features in a minute but one of the big
things about laboratory automation of
course is that you want to ensure that
you are set up properly because once you
hit go you can no longer intervene or
stop the run and potentially Rectify an
error that the user had done with this
setup
so it's really important to ensure
proper loading before you start your run
otherwise you jeopardize the whole the
whole run and potentially completely
waste your samples
so again it speaks to the expertise of
the junk script team that has developed
this our our knowledge of the different
pain points of automation
so what you're seeing here is basically
a feature of the platform before you
start your run where you scan the lab
where the the user has loaded onto the
deck so row number one you're seeing
what is loaded from a tip perspective so
you can see the instrument says yes yes
yes so all six positions have been
loaded the second row is the reagent
cartridges and you can see that it
actually is giving you
a number so this is actually the barcode
so the reagent cartridges are actually
equipped with a barcode that are read
using that scan feature then the
reaction tubes the sample tubes and
finally that waste so you probably
recall that I had mentioned earlier that
the system is completely modular that
means that you do not have to run six
samples at a time so this particular
example the six samples are loaded
because obviously we want to run six
samples but in reality the user does not
have to have this setup completely
filled up so you could potentially have
half or maybe even one sample if you
choose but instead of yes you will end
up seeing no so it gives the user a
visual indication of whether or not the
system
is fully set up
or partially set up and the user will
have a visual check to confirm that what
they are seeing is indeed what they
should what they um should be loading
after that they'll go ahead and hit
start and one again one of the very nice
features is that the system will give
you a calculated number of how long the
instrument will take to complete the Run
of course that's dependent on the
program that you are selecting if you
want to do let's say less washes or less
binding or maybe a different a different
illusion time all those factors are
going to impact how long the run is
going to take so it's going to give you
that countdown
and the last screen I have for you is to
show you during the Run what the user
has the ability to see so during the run
the user can walk up to in the
instrument and see in real time what
step of the process the instrument has
conducted and completed and what step
it's currently running so you can see
here that the system has ran through the
resuspension the license the
neutralization and it is currently at
the pre-clarification step it has yet to
run the supernative transfer as well as
The Binding along with multiple washers
and finally the illusion what you're
seeing on the bottom right hand corner
again is a countdown of how long is left
on the run so let's say the scientist
gets distracted and they end up you know
not paying attention to how much time is
left over on their run not a problem
they can walk up to the instrument check
what step it's on and also check how
much time is left in the run so that's
basically another very nice feature that
really enables you to plan your day
effectively
now I'm going to be talking a little bit
about the performance data which I hope
you find to be useful and of course the
point here is to give you an idea of
what to expect if you were to choose to
work with the Emma Quattro solution
so for the first case study what we did
is compare side by side
the purification using the Emma Quattro
in a manual solution and we actually did
it with two different plasmids
so the first two samples that you're
seeing here were ran on the Emma cuatro
which was Puck DNA 3.1 handbook DNA 3.4
and the second two uh samples that
you're seeing sample three and four were
ran using a manual kit again 3.1 and 3.4
so it was really a side-by-side analysis
and what you're seeing here is that we
ended up looting the Emma Quattro with
one ml volume
and we eluded the um the manual solution
with 500 micrometer so it wasn't truly
the same from an illusion standpoint but
I do want to mention here that you can
technically go down
with the Emma Quattro to an illusion of
500 it was just that particular setup
that the team conducted they chose to go
with one MO
um so what you're seeing here is from a
concentration what we ended up with was
about one make
per milliliter for the Emma Quattro and
about 1500 Meg per milliliter for the
manual solution but again of course the
janscript solution was more dilute so in
reality our concentration was a little
bit higher when we looked at the manual
versus the automated system
however the other metrics
OD to 6280 to 6230 endotoxin levels as
well as the super cold ratio were
basically equivalent
that again indicates the purification
setup as well as the outcome of the
purity of the plasmid and the form of
the of the Osment so of course that's
again indication of whether or not
you're going to be successful in the
downstream application
and the last thing I want to mention is
the gel to the right hand side so we ran
a side-by-side analysis um gel
electrophoresis using the four samples
that remember and you can see basically
the purity of the plasmid as well as the
format of the plasmid whether or not
it's a super cold ratio
so for the second case study I wanted to
mention a couple notes here it's really
important to keep in mind that whenever
you're doing a plasmid setup
what you the limiting factor always is
going to be is of course the plasmid
itself whether or not you're working
with a high copy plasmid a low copy
plasmid if you're working with an insert
that's toxic
another factor of course the growth
conditions another Factor would be the
actual media that is being used for the
growth
so one thing that a lot of you a lot of
scientists end up working with it's
typically lb media which is not
necessarily a very rich media so the
growth conditions are not always going
to be optimal
a lot of scientists end up choosing to
work with terrific broth because of
course it's a very rich media so they
end up seeing more robust results with
the terrific broth so for this
particular example what we ended up
doing is we grew 100 ml TB and 100 MLB
and we compared them side by side across
six samples so three samples for lb and
three samples for TB
and when we weight that bacterial
culture once we centrifuged it down what
we saw is about 0.8 grams for the lb on
average and about 1.2 grams for the TB
I have to say that I've seen actually
sometimes double for the TB again it
really has to do with the plasmid as
well as the other conditions that impact
the growth of the bacteria and the
plasmid itself
for this purpose for this case study
what you're seeing here is is typically
also something that scientists would
also expect so about a 30 percent
increase in the growth of the bacteria
itself
what's really interesting is that once
we purified the plasmid and got to
constant got to the concentration aspect
for the lp culture even though it was
about 30 percent more growth more
bacteria
we ended up with about 400 nanograms per
micro liter in the concentration of the
plasmid however the TB was actually
close to 800 so almost double even
though again the bacteria was a closer
to 30 percent so not only did the
bacteria grow more but the plasmid
itself was more optimal the actual
plasmid replication was more enhanced in
the TB culture
uh with regards to the ODS the 260 280
260 230 the endotoxin levels as well as
the super cold ratios those were all
comparable
so again this case study is just to give
you an indication of what to expect when
you're doing different conditions this
is not necessarily the Emma Quattro
itself
the next case study I would like to give
you is more about the downstream
application which shows the protein
expression
which of course is an indication of
whether or not the plasmid itself is
clean and is going to be successful for
the protein expression aspect
so what you're seeing here is that we
grew a total of six samples in 150 ml
overnight 16 hours
and what we did is we did 50 MLB and and
50 uh sorry 50 lb and 50 to xyt those
are those are two different Medias that
were basically mixed together so 2x2yt
is a little bit richer than lb but
definitely not as rich as TB
and the plasmid that was used was a puck
DNA which of course is a high copy
plasmid so what you're seeing here on
the on the left hand side is the table
showing the concentration of the plasmid
as well as the 260 to a 260 to 80 to 60
to 30 and then the illusion volume so
you can see that approximately across
the board what we ended up with was
about 400 to 500 nanograms per
microliters
so we took these six samples and we did
the same setup using a manual kit so the
same setup as I mentioned before the
cultural volume the culture time the
actual media the plasmid everything was
replicated in an identical manner but
again it was purified using the menu
okay
on the right hand side what you're
seeing is actually the expression the
protein expression we took the manual a
purified plasmid and we took the Emma
Quattro purified plasmid and we
transfected them into the host and we
measured the expression level
and what you're seeing is basically on
the um on the left hand side the bar
that's gray is the manual
um a plasmid and the bar that is green
is going to be the Emma Quattro plasmid
so plasma number one was basically
equivalent plasmid two was a little bit
was definitely higher for the Quattro
again three was more equivalent four was
more manual and so forth and so on so on
average what you should be expecting
with the Amma cuatro is equivalent
performance to a manual kit that's
really the essence of this case study
the next case study I have is also in
relation to the transfection efficiency
very similar to the study before what
we're trying to show here is whether or
not the actual
purity of the plasma DNA that is
obtained from the Emma Quattro is going
to enable you to be successful in your
Downstream application
so what we did here is actually get a
controlled plasmid and manually prepped
control plasmid from our service
department I think everyone probably on
the call have heard of janscript
services team this is really one of the
most
you know experienced
departments that we have at jenscript
they're really well known for providing
high quality plasma DNA
which was really considered one of the
top industry standards
so by using the plasmid that is provided
by them we of course would would expect
high quality results so what we ended up
doing here is we tested using luciferase
reporter G
and we ran two additional samples using
the Amma cuatra and what we ended up
doing is uh testing the luminescence
that is again indicating
um the transfection efficiency using the
um the uh plasmid that was prepared by
the services department which is the
plot that you're seeing in blue versus
the two samples that were ran on the
Emma Quattro which is the plot that
you're seeing in purple in green
um and what you're seeing in front of
you is actually the Gen script uh
prepared plasmid performed
um
actually better than the manual solution
so again it speaks to the performance of
of the actual Emma Quattro purification
getting you to that really pure plasmid
and getting you to the successful
results that you want to see when you're
doing transfection
so in summary here test case number one
Inc test case number two so the purple
and the green Bars were both showing
better transfection efficiency than the
manual kit
in the last case study I have for you
today is actually showing a plenty
transfection efficiency so what we did
here was a little bit different than the
two other case studies so we did a
plenty
Vector so it's actually a three uh part
uh plasmid right I'm sure a lot of
people on the call would probably
um are probably experts in this
so we did the purification again using a
ma Quattro so you're seeing the top a
left hand side table
showing the Amma Quattro purification
and then the bottom one sample number
two is the control which again was done
using a manual kit the Illusion for the
Emma Quattro was 1.5 ml and then the
Illusion for the control was
um basically 500 so one third
and the reason why we did that is
actually it was on purpose so I'll
explain that in a minute we wanted to
show whether or not the purity of the
plasmid again is going to be a key
factor in showing the actual titer the
actual transfection efficiency of the
Plenty title
so what you're seeing here is that the
bottom table
is that what we ended up doing is that
we replicated the two samples the
control and we replicated the two
samples the Mac water so one and two
were the control and then three and four
were the Emma Quattro so what you're
seeing to the to the right hand side of
that table is the average tighter
so for the control you're seeing about
50 uh for the uh Tighter and about uh
same thing for the Amma cuatro
approximately 50. even though the
concentration of the plasma DNA was
one-third so again going back to that
table on the top side um on the top uh
is that the concentration was closest
closer to 300 nanogram per microliter
for the Emma Quattro and about one
milligram per milliliter for the control
so again even though it was one-third
the dilution of the actual control group
The Emma Quattro showed equivalent
performance with regards to the
transfection efficiency
and now I actually have a video for you
that I would like to show you
um a couple things I want to highlight
before I show the video is that the
actual
um Quattro is equipped with not only the
scanning to enable seamless loading but
it is also equipped with puncturing
tools that way when you load your
consumable onto the deck
um it is completely enclosed and
maintained so there's no potential
cross-contamination and also the system
is equipped with index mixers those
induct mixers will enable us to really
bind
um the plasma DNA as well as really
ensure the plasmid is mixed well and
cleaned up properly
so those were all key components in
ensuring not only a very
seamless process but also a very clean
DNA and very clean process to ensure
there's no potential cross-contamination
so with that said I'll go ahead and hit
play
all right
so with that I'm I'm basically done for
the portion for the Amma cuatro I do
want to take a couple moments to just
mention that um janscript we actually
recently celebrated our 20th anniversary
we've been around for um 20 years and
we've expanded significantly from
a very tiny tiny startup with five
thousand dollars in New Jersey in 2002
all the way to the company that we are
today with multiple divisions multiple
departments
quite a bit of off-the-shelf solutions
which obviously what you saw today
present me presenting on
so the reason why I want to show this is
not to potentially brag about transcript
but I actually want to mention that we
are constantly expanding because we want
to hear about what are the pain points
that you are challenged with as
scientists so if there's something that
you that you need that you do not see if
there's something that that you feel is
is an unmet need please reach out to us
please let us know we want to hear from
you so I definitely invite you to reach
out to us and and potentially make us
your partner again maybe maybe not with
this particular product but with others
we actually have quite a bit of
different off-the-shelf solutions
including reagents and devices
I do want to highlight here that we have
a full protein workflow where you're
seeing to the left hand side is what we
call our a magaza plus which is a
completely
very simple
semi-automated and very affordable
automated purification setup you can do
protein and or antibody purification and
you can actually do it in a 12 sample
setup
and it takes really a significantly less
amount of time you can actually do it in
about an hour for 12 samples
um we also have electrophoresis and
Western blotting Solutions whether
you're just doing a a gel run or the
Precast shells that we have our sure
page Jaws are really good performing
they have loading capacity that exceeds
a lot of the products that are offered
in the industry it's the wall shape that
they have
we also have a wet staining system we
call it the e-stain we have a we have
our e-block which basically enables you
to transfer and then we have an
automated Western device so a full
protein
purific protein workflow including
purification to the analysis
and lastly I want to conclude with a
sneak peek into a system that we're
currently working on so this is
something that is not launched
and it's a completely automated protein
purification setup it's going to be a
larger scale so what I showed you before
the a MAG is say plus the capacity of
that system is going to be 50 ml you can
technically condense your sample down by
spinning it or by um by um grabbing the
magnetic beads and moving them into a
tube uh however this the system that
you're seeing here that I mentioned a
minute ago is currently in development
is going to be completely automated and
it's going to be higher throughput and
one of the really nice things about it
is going to be the UV uh read app so
you're going to be able to test the
concentration as well as the various
metrics of the sample on the go as the
sample is getting purified
so we're really excited about the system
uh please expect to see it hopefully in
the next couple months hopefully in the
next quarter or this following one so I
thank you very much for your time today
and I hope that you found that the
information I provided informative and
again I hope that you reach out with
anything that you might need or even if
you just want to bounce some ideas
around so thank you very much and I'll
take any questions you have now
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar break the bottleneck automate
plasmid Maxi prep with am mag Quattro I
am Sabrina lamus of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by genscript to learn more please
visit genscript.com we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send and we'll answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical questions here as well if
you're having trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation I'd now like to welcome
our speaker Ruba Najjar head of product
marketing at the genscript product
division before Aruba begins her
presentation we do have a quick poll
question so please take a moment to
select the answer that best fits the
question
for you and
after some time with that
Ruba you can begin your presentation
welcome
it's really exciting to be presenting to
you today thank you very much for taking
the time to join us as you all heard my
name is Ruben ajar and um be your
presenter for today
I'm gonna be talking about our newest
automated platform the Emma Quattro for
plasmid purification
today I'm going to be talking about uh
quickly about an introduction of how we
ended up bringing this product to the
market as well as the products itself
and all the features I'll also take you
through the workflow followed by the
test data and the performance and lastly
I'm going to be talking about the
related products that could help you
whether you're working upstream or
Downstream from plasmid purification and
I will be giving you a sneak peek into
our next project that we're actively
working on at janscript
so I actually started my career early on
with plasmid purification and it was one
of the most challenging and most tedious
pain points that I got to experience in
a laboratory
um later on I ended up working with
automation at various roles including as
a user as well as a company that
actually made the robotic liquid
handling platforms and I was able to get
a sense of what are the wonderful
aspects of our automation as well as the
limitations of automation so I hope that
what you see today from the solution
standpoint is going to be delivering on
some of those pain points and
eliminating the challenges that are more
limiting in the automation world
so plasmids have actually been around
for many many years coming up actually
on 100 years
the actual term plasmid was introduced
in early 50s and it was around the 70s
that the DNA cloning technology was
introduced around 1980s was when the
purification of the plasmid was finally
done successfully with various Mass
methods
which actually ended up really changing
the way a lot of the laboratory work
around plasmids and transfecting ended
up taking place
so whenever we talk about plasmids we
have to think about the different
requirements as well as the different
challenges with every
um particular application that plasmids
are being used on
so whenever we're working with plasmids
on a smaller scale or maybe on a
research scale
the requirements are not going to be as
stringent and not as limiting as they
would be in a clinical setting of course
industrial is going to be in between but
that's really going to be closer of
course to the pre-clinical or clinical
grade classmate so the higher up you go
in the scheme of of quality typically
also the requirements for the quantity
so of course when you're doing molecular
cloning you're going to be using smaller
quantities of plasmid DNA when you're
going into the transfection and antibody
production or any kind of therapeutic
production you're going to be using
significantly more plasma DNA and of
course the requirement the quality of
the plasmid is going to be very
different than when you are working with
plasma DNA in a research setting
so of course there's been quite a bit of
different methodology identified for the
purification of the plasmid itself
um quite a bit of them are are going to
be
um you know impacting the downstream
application
um but of course at this point in in the
laboratory setting majority of the
people are really using the alkaline
lysis where you're using chemicals to
burst the E coli cell open to get the
plasmid out of that host that you've
grown it
so of course a lot of the common
methodologies are going to be column
filter based where you have to basically
lice your cell open take that um they
take that license neutralize it and then
of course run it through that column and
take it through the series of washes
followed by illusion
that is of course a very labor intensive
step but that is actually one of the
most commonly used methodologies
every single method that you're seeing
up here has its own
value and it has also its own
um down a downstream application that
could cause challenges
from the janscript perspective we
actually based our Solution on the
magnetic silica beads as we found that
this is really the most optimal way to
handle large scale
volume as well as large scale throughput
so what you're seeing in front of you
right now is actually the traditional
plasmid purification with regards to
again what is typically used which is of
course the filter column
so every step almost every step that
you're seeing here there's typically a
centrifugation stop so you go from your
resuspension of your plasmid of your of
your bacteria into the lysis the
neutralization of course you do a
centrifugation here you do your binding
and then a series of washes which again
require a centrifugation at every single
one of them and lastly your illusion
process is not only very intensive with
regards to pipetting but also very
intensive with regards to centrifugation
as we mentioned earlier
it's also very time consuming and the
biggest challenge ends up coming up
whenever you're working with large
volume of liquid
so you end up severely slowing down I
think that usually people would agree
that if you're working with a mini prop
scale it typically takes you less than
an hour but when you're working with
maxi Mega or even Giga it typically
takes you half a day to purify a very
few samples maybe even three or four and
it ends up taking you a significant
amount of time
so with that said
um the janscript team came up with what
you're seeing in front of you which is a
completely automated large-scale High
throughput plasmid purification solution
the solution is actually an a complete
all-inclusive solution it's not only the
automated platform but it also includes
the verified protocols that are
pre-programmed onto the instrument
the actual consumables as well that are
needed to run the plasmid purification
are also part of the solution so with
that said what the user will end up
obtaining with this one basically one
comprehensive solution is that an out of
the box ready to go set up so the user
theoretically can purchase the system
take it out of the box load their
culture onto it load the actual
consumables and hit go within a few
hours of getting the instrument
so scientists now don't have to do their
their own validation their own
verification we made sure that the
protocols that are pre-grown programmed
into the solution into the system are
actually verified and work very well
with a wide variety of different plasmid
setups
another thing that is that was key in
the design of the instrument which I
think speaks miles of the expertise of
the janscript team and understanding the
pain points of not only throughput but
also automation is the fact that the
solution is actually scalable and
completely modular
so what you're seeing in front of you is
actually to the right hand side is the
controller that can control up to four
modules that are completely independent
of one another
so the four modules to the left hand
side are individual purification modules
that are completely ran independent of
one another so if a scientist is okay
with a setup of six samples at a time
they don't need more than one module so
One controller and one module is capable
of running six samples at a time if
their throughput grows a few months
later not a problem they can add another
module to this setup or maybe a third or
a fourth as their system needs to grow
and they're through book groups
so with that said again I want to
highlight the fact that each one is
completely independent of one another
and each module can be ran and dependent
of one another so if you want to run a
different program or if you want to run
a different um different times of the
day not a problem each one is completely
independent of one another
so as I mentioned before if you have a
four module setup with six samples free
for each module that means you can
actually run 24 samples in one go
system itself of course is a pipe adding
liquid Handler and the Precision of the
padding is really good it's actually a
CV of three percent
and one thing I want to highlight here
is typically that the culture limitation
the volume of the bacterial culture is
not necessarily what I would
basically specify would be the
limitation it's really the bacterial
palette once the sample is centrifuge
down
so the first thing that the you that the
scientist has to do is grow their
culture overnight in their media and
then they have to actually spin down
that culture and weigh that bacterial
wet palette that bacterial palette has a
range that we have
identified to be optimal for the Quattro
set the optimal range is going to be 0.3
to 1.5 bacterial watt pellet
so if you're less than that quality of
the plasmid of the DNA might not be as
good if you're higher than that you're
not going to get good lysis which of
course indicates you're not going to be
able to obtain your DNA which is very
similar to really any kind of
um lysis that this is not unique to the
transcript solution
the run time is going to be
approximately two hours so theoretically
you can typically run this instrument
probably three times a day the runtime
of course varies on depending on the
protocol you that you're running so two
to two and a half hours are going to be
the typical run times
what you will end up with is
transfection ready purified plasmid
which of course means High Purity
plasmid that has low endotoxins
below 0.1 EU per microgram and a very
high super cold ratio which is exceeding
the 80 to 90 percent ratio that is
typically indicative of the quality of
the plasmid that you're working with so
a lot of people think that the super
cold ratio is one of the key factors
that are going to be indicating whether
or not you're going to be successful in
your Downstream application so Studies
have actually shown that
and as I mentioned earlier in the slide
before the consumable kit is included in
the solution it includes the the
um the full scope of what is needed to
run the AMA Quattro plasma purification
setup
um the consumable itself is all
inclusive and I'll talk about that in
the next slide but this is something
that I really want to highlight because
it's something that is not typically
done in any kind of um a setup usually
the the user or the scientist has to
actually Supply additional components to
be able to run this solution
and lastly but definitely not least is
the use or the ease of use of the
interface so I mentioned before that the
solution has the pre-programmed verified
protocols
this is again included in this system
however if the scientist wants to
program their own protocol not a problem
they can actually do that using the
interface and I will give you an example
of the interface in a little bit but it
is very user friendly and there's quite
a bit of different checks that we
implemented to ensure correct loading of
the instrument as well as metrics that
don't violate the the various
recommendations that we have that we
know will enable you to be successful
so again it speaks to the expertise of
the JavaScript solution and the team
that actually worked on this platform
and this consumer
so this is basically
um the consumable kit what you're seeing
in front of you is actually the two box
that includes a filter tube that will be
the final illusion to this is loaded up
here in the platform
the next component in the consumable is
the reagent cartridge this reagent
cartridge contains all the magnetic
beads that I mentioned before as well as
the buffers and the wash
wash buffers and the illusion
it also includes all the tubes as well
as the waste so as you can see here it
is an all-inclusive kit you do not need
to worry about ordering multiple
components to run this platform it is
completely
completely included in one it's all in
one
and one of the nice things about the
transcript kit is that it is very cost
effective one of the biggest things
about Maxi Mega and gigapreps the fact
that the actual cost per sample is
fairly High
um so of course when you automate
typically people want to see some cost
savings whether it's labor or whether
it's from a consumable standpoint you
will see that the consumable for the
janscript solution is actually less than
the market average and again all
inclusive of all the different
components that are needed
so I want to take a couple minutes to
actually introduce you to the full
workflow what you're seeing here within
the blue haloed box is completely
automated so this is not something that
the scientist has to worry about but I
still wanted to take a few moments to
talk about the full workflow because I
do think it's really interesting to
understand how the solution works
everything outside of the haloed box is
actually manual
so as I mentioned before the first step
of course when you're doing plasmid
purification is to grow your culture
offline
once your culture is grown you're going
to take your a Mac Watcher tube and
you're going to centrifuge your culture
using that mmac Watcher tube so one of
the big things about using the
consumables is that they're
pre-configured to fit into the janscript
solution but they also have other
components tied to the way that the
system works so for example the tube
that is used in the genscript setup
uh actually has internal baffles that
enables really good resuspension of the
bacterial palette as well as really good
mixing when you're binding that plasmid
DNA so that particular tube is going to
be used to go ahead and load your
bacterial palette into it so one thing
that the scientists can choose if they
are working with a really large volume
they could potentially centrifuge the
bacterial palette using their own flask
and then remove that that bacteria
palette scoop it out and put it into the
tube or again they can use that that
tube to basically spin down the culture
once the spinning down of the culture is
done you go ahead and you load your
bacterial palette onto the instrument
deck of course you pour off that
supinated you load your tips you load
your tubes and of course you load your
reagent cartridge you go ahead and hit
start
and again everything you're seeing in
that blue haloed box is completely
automated so the instrument will take
the first step of basically resuspending
the bacterial palette it's going to do
the lysis the neutralization followed by
the pre-clarification
stuff which of course is usually
removing the host DNA as well as the
cell debris and other contaminating
components once the cell has been lysed
that of course includes proteins RNA all
kinds of contaminants that would be in
your in your solution
after you remove that debris and that
contaminating
um
um basically components you're going to
go ahead and bind your plasma DNA after
The Binding the system will go ahead and
do a series of washes
uh that includes specified washes to
include those endotoxins so that will
really enable us to get to that really
pure plasmid
after that the system will go ahead and
perform an illusion
and the final step is to remove that
illusion remove
um
the full
supernatant and dispenser into that I
you probably remember from my previous
slide into that illusion tube that
contains the filter
so once the illusion tube has been um
the liquid has been dispensed into that
illusion tube the run is complete so the
the scientists will walk up to the
instrument cap that tube containing the
eluded DNA and centrifugal Offline that
final centrifugation step through that
filter in that column is going to remove
any Trace residual endotoxins as well as
any residual magnetic beads this is a
very important step to remove any final
endotoxins so I definitely do not
recommend skipping that step however if
you choose that as something that you
technically can skip
and that's basically it so again
centrifugation at the beginning to
ensure that you are um you know ready to
go into your resuspension and then
centrifugation after you've done your
illusion those are the only two manual
uh setups at the beginning and of course
at the end of The Run
what you're seeing now is the user
interface which the first screen that
you're seeing on the top left corner is
showing you the main controller so as I
mentioned before the actual controller
can control up to four modules and this
for this particular example you can see
that the what the system is connected to
only one module so only one module is
online while the remainder modules are
great at because they're technically
offline
offline um when you go into module
number one there's a couple different
settings that you can actually select
from you can do the programming you can
export this is basically exporting the
runs that you have conducted before you
can go into the general settings and of
course you can do system upgrades on the
instrument itself
basically this is just showing you the
different parameters that the user will
have control over
so this is actually my favorite part of
the interface
um or maybe my second favorite I'll talk
about a couple other features in a
minute but one of the big things about
laboratory automation of course is that
you want to ensure that you are set up
properly because once you hit go you can
no longer intervene or stop the run and
potentially Rectify an error that the
user had done with this setup so it's
really important to ensure proper
loading before you start your run
otherwise you jeopardize the whole the
whole run and potentially completely
waste your samples
so again it speaks to the expertise of
the janscript team that has developed
this our our knowledge of the different
pain points of automation
so what you're seeing here is basically
a feature of the platform before you
start your run where you scan the lab
where that the user has loaded onto the
deck so row number one you're seeing
what is loaded from a tip perspective so
you can see the instrument says yes yes
yes so all six positions have been
loaded the second row is the reagent
cartridges and you can see that it
actually is giving you
a number so this is actually the barcode
so the reagent cartridges are actually
equipped with a barcode that are read
using that scan feature then the
reaction tubes the sample tubes and
finally that waste so you probably
recall that I had mentioned earlier that
the system is completely modular that
means that you do not have to run six
samples at a time so this particular
example the six samples are loaded
because obviously we want to run six
samples but in reality
the user does not have to have this
setup completely filled up so you could
potentially have half or maybe even one
sample if you choose but instead of yes
you will end up singing no so it gives
the user a visual indication of whether
or not the system
is fully set up
or partially set up and the user will
have a visual check to confirm that what
they are seeing is indeed what they
should what they should be loading after
that they'll go ahead and hit start and
one again one of the very nice features
is that the system will give you a
calculated number of how long the
instrument will take to complete the Run
of course that's dependent on the
program that you are selecting if you
want to do let's say less washes or less
binding or maybe a different a different
illusion time all those factors are
going to impact how long the run is
going to take so it's going to give you
that countdown
and the last screen I have for you is to
show you during the Run what the user
has the ability to see so during the run
the user can walk up to in the
instrument and see in real time what
step of the process the instrument has
conducted and completed and what step
it's currently running so you can see
here that the system has ran through the
resuspension the lysis the
neutralization and it is currently at
the pre-clarification step
has yet to run the supernatan transfer
as well as The Binding along with
multiple washers and finally the
illusion what you're seeing on the
bottom right hand corner again is a
countdown of how long is left on the run
so let's say the scientist gets
distracted and they end up you know not
paying attention to how much time is
left over on their run not a problem
they can walk up to the instrument check
what step it's on and also check how
much time is left in the run so that's
basically another very nice feature that
really enables you to plan your day
effectively
now I'm going to be talking a little bit
about the performance data which I hope
you find to be useful and of course the
point here is to give you an idea of
what to expect if you were to choose to
work with the Emma cuatro solution so
for the first case study what we did is
compare side by side
the purification using the Amma Quadro
in a manual solution and we actually did
it with two different plasmids
so the first two samples that you're
seeing here were ran on the Emma cuatro
which was Puck DNA 3.1 had bug DNA 3.4
and the second two samples that you're
seeing sample three and four were ran
using a manual kit again 3.1 and 3.4 so
it was really a side-by-side analysis
and what you're seeing here is that we
ended up looting the Amma cuatro with
one ml volume
and we eluded the um the manual solution
with 500 micrones
so it wasn't truly the same from an
illusion standpoint but I do want to
mention here that you can technically go
down
with the Emma Quattro to an illusion of
500 it was just that particular setup
that the team conducted they chose to go
with one MO
um so what you're seeing here is from a
concentration what we ended up with was
about one make
per milliliter for the Emma Quattro and
about 1500 Meg per milliliter for the
manual solution but again of course the
janscript solution was more dilute so in
reality our concentration was a little
bit higher when we looked at the manual
versus the automated system
however the other metrics
OD 26280 to 6230 endotoxin levels as
well as the super cold ratio were
basically equivalent
that again indicates the purification
setup as well as the outcome of the
purity of the plasmid and the form of
the plasmid so of course that's again
indication of whether or not you're
going to be successful in the downstream
application
and the last thing I want to mention is
the gel to the right hand side so we ran
a side-by-side analysis um gel
electrophoresis using the four samples
that remember and you can see basically
the purity of the plasmid as well as the
format of the plasmid whether or not
it's a super cold ratio
so for the second case study I wanted to
mention a couple notes here it's really
important to keep in mind that whenever
you're doing a plasmid setup
what you the limiting factor always is
going to be as a is of course the
plasmid itself whether or not you're
working with a high copy plasmid a low
copy plasmid if you're working with an
insert that's toxic
another factor of course the growth
conditions another Factor would be the
actual media that is being used for the
growth
so one thing that a lot of you a lot of
scientists end up working with it's
typically lb media which is not
necessarily a very rich media so the
growth conditions are not always going
to be optimal
a lot of scientists end up choosing to
work with terrific broth because of
course it's a very rich media so they
end up seeing more robust results with
the terrific broth so for this
particular example what we ended up
doing is we grew 100 ml TB and 100 MLB
and we compared them side by side across
six samples so three samples for lb and
three samples for TB
and when we weight that bacterial
culture once we centrifuged it down what
we saw is about 0.8 grams for the lb on
average and about 1.2 grams for the TB
I have to say that I've seen actually
sometimes double for the TV again it
really has to do with the plasmid as
well as the other conditions that impact
the growth of the bacteria and the
plasmid itself
for this purpose for this case study
what you're seeing here is is typically
also something that scientists would
also expect so about a 30 percent
increase in the growth of the bacteria
itself
what's really interesting is that once
we purified the plasmid and got to
constant got to the concentration aspect
for the lb culture even though it was
about 30 percent more growth more
bacteria
we ended up with about 400 nanograms per
micro liter in the concentration of the
plasmid however the TB was actually
close to 800 so almost double even
though again the bacteria was a closer
to 30 percent so not only did the
bacteria grow more but the plasmid
itself was more optimal the actual
a plasmid replication was more enhanced
in the TB culture
with regards to the ODS the 260 280 to
6230 the endotoxin levels as well as the
super cold ratios those were all
comparable
so again this case study is just to give
you an indication of what to expect when
you're doing different conditions this
is not necessarily the Emma Quattro
itself
the next case study I would like to give
you is more about the downstream
application which shows the protein
expression
uh which of course is an indication of
whether or not the plasmid itself is
clean and is going to be successful for
the protein expression aspect
so what you're seeing here is that we
grew a total of six samples and 150 ml
overnight 16 hours
and what we did is we did 50 MLB and and
50 uh sorry 50 lb and 50 2xyt those are
those are two different Medias that were
basically mixed together so 2x2yt is a
little bit richer than lb but definitely
not as rich as TB
and the plasmid that was used was a puck
DNA which of course is a high copy
plasmid so what you're seeing here on
the on the left hand side is the table
showing the concentration of the plasmid
as well as the 260 to a 260 to 80 to 60
to 30 and then the illusion volume so
you can see that approximately across
the board what we ended up with was
about 400 to 500 nanograms per
microliters
so we took these six samples and we did
the same setup using a manual kit so the
same setup as I mentioned before the
cultural volume the culture time the
actual media the plasmid everything was
replicated in an identical manner but
again it was purified using the menu
okay
on the right hand side what you're
seeing is actually the expression the
protein expression we took the manual a
purified plasmid and we took the Amma
Quattro purified plasmid and we
transfected them into the host and we
measured the expression level
and what you're seeing is basically on
the um on the left hand side the bar
that's gray is the manual
plasmid and the bar that is green is
going to be the Emma quattroplasmid so
plasma number one was basically
equivalent plasmid 2 was a little bit
was definitely higher for the Quattro
again three was more equivalent four was
more manual and so forth and so on so on
average what you should be expecting
with the Emma Quattro is equivalent
performance to a manual kit that's
really the essence of this case study
the next case study I have is also in
relation to the transfection efficiency
very similar to the study before what
we're trying to show here is whether or
not the actual
purity of the plasma DNA that is
obtained from the Emma Quattro is going
to enable you to be successful in your
Downstream application
so what we did here is actually get a
control plasmid and manually prepped
control plasmid from our service
department I think everyone probably on
the call have heard of janscript
services team this is really one of the
most
you know experienced
departments that we have at janscript
they're really well known for providing
a high quality plasma DNA which is
really considered one of the top
industry standards
so by using the plasmid that is provided
by them we of course would would expect
high quality results
so what we ended up doing here is we
tested using luciferase reporter G
and we ran two additional samples using
the Amma cuatra and what we ended up
doing is uh testing the luminescence
that is again indicating
um the transfection efficiency using the
um the uh plasmid that was prepared by
the services department which is the
plot that you're seeing in blue versus
the two samples that were ran on the
Emma Quattro which is the plot that
you're seeing in purple in green
um and what you're seeing in front of
you is actually the Gen script uh
prepared plasmid performed
um
actually better than the manual solution
so again it speaks to the performance of
of the actual Emma Quattro purification
getting you to that really pure plasmid
and getting you to the successful
results that you want to see when you're
doing transfection
so in summary here test case number one
Inc test case number two so the purple
and the green Bars were both showing
better transfection efficiency than the
manual kit
and the last case study I have for you
today is actually showing a plenty
transaction efficiency so what we did
here was a little bit different than the
two other case studies so we did a
plenty
Vector so it's actually a three uh part
plasmid right I'm sure a lot of people
on the call would probably
um are probably experts in this so we
did the purification again using Emma
Quattro so you're seeing the top a left
hand side table
showing the ma Quattro purification and
then the bottom one sample number two is
the control which again was done using a
manual kit the Illusion for the Emma
Quattro was 1.5 ml and then the Illusion
for the control was
um basically 500 so one third
and the reason why we did that is
actually it was on purpose so
um I'll explain that in a minute we
wanted to show whether or not the purity
of the plasmid again is going to be a
key factor in showing the actual tighter
the actual transaction efficiency of the
Plenty title
so what you're seeing here is that the
bottom table
is that what we ended up doing is that
we replicated the two samples the
control and we replicated the two
samples the Mac Watchers so one and two
were the control and then three and four
were the Emma Quattro so what you're
seeing to the to the right hand side of
that table is the average tighter
so for the control you're seeing about
50 uh for the uh Tighter and about uh
same thing for the Amma Quattro
approximately 50. even though the
concentration of the plasma DNA was
one-third so again going back to that
table on the top side um on the top uh
is that the concentration was closest
closer to 300 nanogram per microliter
for the Amma cuatro and about one
milligram per milliliter for the control
so again even though it was one-third
the dilution of the actual
um control group The Emma Quattro showed
equivalent performance with regards to
the transfection efficiency
and now I actually have a video for you
that I would like to show you
um a couple things I want to highlight
before I show the video is that the
actual Quattro is equipped with not only
the scanning to enable seamless loading
but it is also equipped with puncturing
tools that way when you load your
consumable onto the deck
um it is completely enclosed and
maintained so there's no potential
cross-contamination
and also the system is equipped with
index mixers those index mixers will
enable us to really bind
um the plasma DNA as well as really
ensure the plasmid is mixed well and
cleaned up properly
so those were all key components in
ensuring not only a very
seamless process but also a very clean
DNA and very clean process to ensure
there's no potential cross-contamination
so with that said I'll go ahead and hit
play
all right
so with that I'm I'm basically done for
the portion for the Amma cuatro I do
want to take a couple moments to just
mention that um janscript we actually
recently celebrated our 20th anniversary
we've been around for um 20 years and
we've expanded significantly from
a very tiny tiny startup with five
thousand dollars in New Jersey in 2002
all the way to the company that we are
today with multiple divisions multiple
departments and quite a bit of
off-the-shelf solutions which obviously
what you saw today present me presenting
on
so the reason why I want to show this is
not to potentially brag about janscript
but I actually want to mention that we
are constantly expanding because we want
to hear about what are the pain points
that you are challenged with as
scientists so if there's something that
you that you need that you do not see if
there's something that that you feel is
is an unmet need please reach out to us
please let us know we want to hear from
you so I definitely invite you to reach
out to us and and potentially make us
your partner again maybe maybe not with
this particular product but with others
we actually have quite a bit of
different off-the-shelf solutions
including reagents and devices
I do want to highlight here that we have
a full protein workflow where you're
seeing to the left hand side is what we
call our a magaza plus which is a
completely
very simple
semi-automated and very affordable
automated purification setup you can do
protein and or antibody purification and
you can actually do it in a 12 sample
setup
and it takes really a significantly less
amount of time you can actually do it in
about an hour for 12 samples
um we also have electrophoresis and
Western blotting Solutions whether
you're just doing a a gel run or the
Precast shelves that we have our sure
page Jaws are really good performing
they have loading capacity that exceeds
a lot of the products that are offered
in the industry it's the wall shape that
they have
we also have a wet staining system we
call it the e-stain we have a we have
our e-block which basically enables you
to transfer and then we have an
automated Western device so a full
protein a perfect protein workflow
including purification to the analysis
and lastly I want to conclude with a
sneak peek into the system that we're
currently working on so this is
something that is not launched and it's
a completely automated protein
purification setup it's going to be a
larger scale so what I showed you before
the emag is say plus the capacity of
that system is going to be 50 ml you can
technically condense your sample down by
spinning it or by um by um grabbing the
magnetic beads and moving them into a
tube uh however this the system that
you're seeing here that I mentioned a
minute ago is currently in development
is going to be completely automated and
it's going to be higher throughput and
one of the really nice things about it
is going to be the UV uh read app so
you're going to be able to test the
concentration as well as various metrics
of the sample on the go as the sample is
getting purified
so we're really excited about the system
uh please expect to see it hopefully in
the next couple months hopefully in the
next quarter or this following one so I
thank you very much for your time today
and I hope that you found that the
information I provided informative and
again I hope that you reach out with
anything that you might need or even if
you just want to bounce some ideas
around so thank you very much and I'll
take any questions you have now
thank you Ruba for your informative
presentation before we begin the live q
a portion of the webinar we do have a
couple of poll questions so if you could
please take a look and answer as you see
fit
okay so we have the next poll question
up if you could answer that one as well
that would be much appreciated and then
there's one more after this thank you so
much for your participation
all right and then just this last poll
question here
foreign
all right so thank you so much for
participating in those polls we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
okay thank you so much for all the
questions we have coming in
um Ruba the first one that I'm seeing is
how long of centrifugin at the end is
needed
it's typically about five minute
centrifugation
pretty quick
hey wonderful
um next one I see does the tube fit
standard centrifuge rotors and says
scooping up bacteria pellet seems a
little bit messy
yes it does so it's basically almost
identical to a 50 ml conical tube uh the
bottom is circle but that's really the
only thing but majority of centrifuges
can handle that if not you can
definitely switch out your rotor
great
um do you give on-site demos
we do have a demo program that's not a
problem uh we can definitely talk to you
offline about what of course where
you're located all that and kind of
figure out the logistics from there
wonderful
um is the excuse me is the Aleutian
volume fixed at one milliliter
it's not it's actually something that
you can control
great and what is the largest culture it
can process
so it's not really the culture volume
that is the limitation again it really
depends on the plasmid how much it grew
it's really going to be by the bacterial
pellet weight and I can definitely give
more details about that offline
um but it definitely the limitation
isn't necessarily by the volume
okay and can you add a HEPA filter is
the unit closed or sealed somewhat
so the unit is actually enclosed it's
not enclosed by a HEPA but it does have
a UV light you could potentially
um throw it in a hood it is a bit tall
to be thrown into a hood but it is
equipped with a UV light so you can
definitely turn on that UV in between
runs you can turn on the UV overnight if
you choose to do so
um and of course the tips themselves
that are processing the samples uh they
are they are filter tips
great thank you
um do you plan on scaling up to a mega
or Giga prep levels in the future
that is something we are actually
actively working on we are working on
optimizing the scale uh both lower scale
and higher scale uh it definitely is
possible that in the future we can get
to the mega or even Giga scale
great um next one I have here what
exactly is the Aleutian buffer is it H2O
or other
um we actually have a few offers we do
have water and we also have tea
great
um and let's see next one
is the culture tube also included in the
kit how does the tube look like or do I
need a special rotor
the tube is included in the kit it is uh
as I mentioned earlier it is a it is
almost identical to what 50 ml conical
the only thing is the bottom uh portion
of that tube majority of the tubes that
are available in the market they have a
bit of a V shape the tube that we are
using on the Emma Quattro it is uh more
circular so if you do have a rotary
bucket that collides with that shape it
would be good to switch at that base
uh I've used a lot of different
centrifuges every single manufacturer do
have a different bucket so it's not
something that would be a challenge for
you I would imagine you probably already
have it in the lab uh if you don't
already
okay and then next one I have is the end
product sterile
so as I mentioned before the tips are
filtered the actual consumable is
completely enclosed so there should be
no risk of cross-contamination
whatsoever
um the final illusion stop that takes
the supernatant the eleu through that
filter tube uh that will do also another
as a fair sorry a filter sterile
centrifugation so you will end up with
technically a stero uh sterile plasmid
yes
great and does this instrument purify
back mids around 160 KB with no or
minimal shearing
so as you already saw from my
presentation a lot of the test data we
have conducted
um
um I actually not exactly sure what is
the size of of um like what is the um
number exactly of the bacterial palettes
that we were purifying uh however you
can definitely see that the uh the super
cold ratio was fairly High which means
of course that this plasma isn't getting
sheared so I don't think there should be
an issue
um with the size that was mentioned but
again I'm not exactly sure what the
ratio that we tested against
great and it looks like we have time for
one more question
if I only use part of the kit to run
less than six samples at first can I
save the rest of the kit to run
remaining samples later
yes not a problem
so I think you probably heard me
mentioning earlier that the fact that
the system is completely modular
so when I met by modular is that you can
run one or six samples you can run
anything in between so you don't have to
have it completely filled up to run and
there's absolutely no waste so it's not
like you have to partially run
okay great and it looks like we have one
last question that just popped up your
gels looked very clean but they were cut
off do you have the full gel with ladder
I'm asking about contamination it says
uh I do have the full gel not a problem
I can definitely
um share that with the participant
offline
um
not a problem
awesome thank you so much thank you
again Ruba for your time today and your
important research we'd also like to
thank the lab Roots our sponsor and gen
script for underwriting today's
educational webcast do you have any
final final condiments for the audience
Ruba
just thank you for your time today
really appreciate it I hope I hope
everyone has a great day
thank you so much before we'd go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event until next time thank you so much
everybody goodbye